小哥要來教我們
葛蘭壁八大法則
跟著葛蘭壁八大法則
而且小哥有賺到一千%
葛蘭壁八法很好用
難道小哥還能交出
不一樣的新高度嗎
葛蘭壁太晚認識我
覺得就是籌碼跟教量
做我都幫他補強了
幫今天就建議
但是復花禮什麼叫過
大概20、40、48、60、47
這個我們就怎麼樣
有沒有99%會反彈的
有 虎架跳水有分兩種
一有水花 二沒水花
有亮就是有水花
有水花的才漂亮
殺到這一根的時候出亮
後面整個彈上來
這彈好高耶
這個彈得太誇張了
小哥
我們不是有體重競賽之約嗎
對啊
我覺得狀況很奇怪
剛剛兩個稍微多一點點
因為趙華完全就是站在
你知道大盤方
緩跌
大盤跌多少
趙華現在跌了1公斤
可是你很奇怪耶
我知道你在那是什麼啦
你在那你的獲利方
你逆勢還上漲了什麼回事
我稍微反彈一點點
為什麼咧
因為聽說你們要上電視啦
對啊 我今天穿比較正式一點
穿正式不是
因為皮帶3公斤
皮帶3公斤
不是 不是 我知道
小樂 你不是皮帶3公斤
不是什麼
皮帶下面的可能有3公斤
就是腿啦 腿啦
你要講清楚
我怕女粉絲太多
不過你這樣子的話
那你只是物理性變瘦啊
物理性變瘦
因為你就是照一個深色的啊
你有沒有真正實際想要變色
有啊我有去健身啊
你有沒有去健身
有啊你看到我的胸部
還有
還有一點動喔
鏡頭不知道不知道是不是
有啦 有一點點
有耶
對我不好意思動太厲害
我怕那個健身又找我去拍
哦健身的廣告
那你去了健身房
有沒有覺得很棒的健身房
健身房喔
對啊
我們那間還好
不過我聽說有個很棒的健身房
健身房 很棒的健身房
可以幹嘛
大家可以跟你講
大家有跟我講
對啊
好 歡迎大家又來到
理財達人秀
那這一集的話
我們的內容會講到的就是
籌碼還有技術現行
我們請到就是我們最厲害的
全正小哥
那小哥剛剛告訴我們
他去了一個神秘的健身房
他去神秘健身房做什麼呢
不過我現在講今天的主題囉
今天的話
小哥要來教我們
常常會聽到的
葛蘭壁八大法則
相信很多做技術現行的人
對這個法則很不陌生吧
那我告訴你 你錯了
如果你之前上過
隔欄壁八大法則的任何課程
請你通通忘記它
所有的書通通丟掉
因為今天我們會有小哥版的
隔欄壁八大法則
小哥啊 小哥教隔欄壁八大法則
很不孫耶 簡稱什麼呢
小哥教隔欄壁八大法則
我們簡稱隔欄
藍 哥藍吧 很怪
聽不好聽
小哥家嘛 哥藍
膠
對
不是
我不是說實際上
不是說實際上還沒有深夜
藍蜜尿科來業配
對
但是沒有關係
因為最近的盤式
我覺得很適合來學
哥藍B幫他發掘
沒錯 很適合
因為現在的盤
只要有一點點反彈
我就認為是回升
你就認為是回升
那我今天要徹底的
這個改正你的觀念
改正我的觀念
先講講你的健身房好了嗎
健身房
投資達人特區的健身房是
欸
現在很多健身房都這一招
打馬賽克
現在網路尺度跟電視是不一樣的小小
網路上看得到電視就馬了
健身房我聽說有個健身房蠻特別的
這健身房不算月的 算次的
我們一次有分1000的普通級
還有5000的VIP級
那一次的普通級是怎麼樣
怎麼樣
那人就 你要一次補東西
那我給你這個體驗看看
好
然後就給那個人
給他一個鑰匙
對
那鑰匙呢
他又拿鑰匙進去打開
裡面做了一個
穿著筆記你的美女
這樣就說
你追我
如果你追到我
就能把我
嘿嘿嘿
哇 這麼好
那一開始追教練
哇 一跑跑了兩小時
終於追到教練
那也如願的那個
就如願的瘦了
如願的瘦了
一兩 哇 少兩公斤
消耗了很多水分
少兩公斤 對
哇 這個健身房太好了
好
那他想說一千塊這麼好
那五千塊的不就更好嗎
當然囉
那五千塊更好
還有我們這是呢
這個五千塊的教練也在
好
也是一樣那天教室
對
就給他一把鑰匙
打開 走進去
走進去就看到一個教練
對
好 這教練呢
哇 各位看一下
這什麼畫面子
這教練是帥哥啦
不是人耶
不是人
對啊
因為大星星
這大星星說
我追你
如果我追到你
我就把你
嘿嘿嘿
哇 他就在裡面
被大星星追了兩小時
一兩少了五公斤
應該是那個用生命在跑
這就是神奇健身房
神奇健身房
因為最近的盤是很像
不是 神奇健身房
我看你小哥怎麼轉回
格蘭必八大法則
有
你可以
最近盤是
各位還記得一件事情
什麼事
我們來看一下
2020年2月4號
這個好
就要跟電視上的朋友說了
如果你早點追蹤
我們的網路YouTube頻道的話
這個你就一定會看到
反彈你就不會誤認為是回生了
特別跟你講說
反彈那天大反彈喔
是
特別寫反彈是讓你逃命的
很多人搶反彈是想要看到黑黑黑
想要去搶嘛
搶個黑黑黑開戲一下
結果一進去遇到大星星
就背
因為後面又黑黑黑
這個反彈呢你要逃命
那為什麼要逃命呢
我來看最後一句
逃命是讓你有資格
搶反彈
非常有選擇一句話喔
逃命你才有這個強反彈
沒錯 命要保則啊
你講沒有逃命的話
哇 現在滿手股票
對
砍這個也不是
砍那個也不是
對 那怎麼強反彈呢
根本沒有辦法強反彈
是
不過我們今天請小哥來教
格蘭壁八大法則
他有一個好處
如果也像趙華一樣
你都會希望他是真的
回升到一個正常的管道
格蘭壁八大法則看得出來
但如果他現在只是反彈
尤其最近的盤是
都是大漲大跌的話
那你要知道
你從格蘭壁八大法則會知道
這只是個反彈喔
對 好的 什麼是反彈
什麼是反彈呢
其實我們第一很簡單
第一個月線往下
月線往下 這很簡單啊
月線往下任何在月線底下
你只能視為反彈
好 20日均線就是月線
它往下的時候
往下的時候
那現在股價在月線下面嗎
站不上 對 站不上
這時候你只能視為反彈
對 那反彈的時候
常常會發生價漲量縮
不過像這邊就算它站上
但因為月線還在往下
還是示威反彈
還是不能去買
因為它只是反彈而已
反彈可以搶
但是它有一些
對 它有一些SOP
待會更多
等一下會交
如果大家真的想要搶反彈
但是如果你不擅長做反彈
就要看懂了
這樣的話你不適合追
這只是反彈而已
那什麼是回升呢
我們要等到月線往上
月線是往上的趨勢
二十日均線往上
月線往上才是回升
那月線往上這個回升的時候
容易是價漲量增
價漲量增
價跌量縮
那如果隨著月線是往上的時候
跌破我也不要怕嗎
月線往上
跌破不用怕
對
跌破你還可以勇敢買進
好
這就是格蘭壁八大法文上面講的
是
好
那反彈跟回升是不大一樣的
總結一張表來看看
好 我們來看一下
這反彈等待時間很短
我們強反彈可能肩搶
有時候這一秒鐘搶
那可能過個五分鐘就出了
回升等待發動的時間就比較久
因為回升可能走一個大波段
所以這兩個不一樣
加量關係反彈 價漲量縮
因為買的人其實會怕
所以價漲量縮
那回升會價漲量增
大家勇敢都進來了
那月線在反彈的時候
月線是往下的
所以我們今天看反彈的時候
月線其實是往下的
只要剛剛有講
有往下的時候
你的骨架其實
就是你骨頭真的滴下去
你只是能搶反彈而已
好 不能抱太久
那回升的時候月星往上
那骨架往上漲的時候
反彈你就要肩嘛
肩嘛
那回升的時候往上漲
你可以考慮加碼
反而要加碼
對 那反彈就是用搶的
反彈要用搶的 要動作快
真正確認回升的時候
就可以慢慢往上
對 你就可以抱久一點
那我們葛蘭碧八法則
真的能夠弄得很清楚嗎
我們來看一下
傻傻分不清楚有沒有
這個葛蘭碧教你判斷反彈跟回升
這是坊間你都看得到的葛蘭碧圖
對啊 這個
難道小哥和人交出不一樣的新高度嗎
有啦 那個葛蘭碧太晚認識我
太晚認識你
對啊 葛蘭碧太晚認識你
七年前走的
對啊
2013年
而且走的時候並不快樂
他並不快樂
他就是沒有看造華節目
你他很播了啦
我2013年就是沒做節目
對啊 每天看你節目
跟我這樣子講話多開心啊
對不對 看了憂鬱症都沒了
是不是
憂鬱症很多都是沒看我們節目
而不是說他沒事做或是不知足
好不好 如果有憂鬱症
不是不知足喔
要趕快去請教專業的專科醫師
多看我們節目也會很快樂
對 好
小哥你還是幫我們講一下
八大法則
是你八大
好 來先看第一個
這個當月線往上的時候
月線往上的時候突破
突破了我們就找買點
突破上揚軍線
那這個軍線是什麼軍線
也是月線嗎
都月線
就是骨架只要突破月線就可以
好 月線
突破月線可以
那第二個買點是月線往上
然後這個骨架跌破月線
跌破月線這個點
這個點也是一個好買點
也是一個好買點
碟破上揚軍 軍線還是上揚的喔
碟破上揚軍線是好買點
在多頭的時候
有時候我們很喜歡搶這個反彈
多頭的時候
這個反彈勝率其實非常高
非常高
但是這邊的話
就是有點搶反彈的意味
就有點搶反彈
而且這種反彈比較安全
因為它越線還是往上
比較安全
好的
那第三個是回撤軍線的時候
對
回撤軍線獲得支撐
是
那這個點也是個買點
好 回測軍線獲得支撐的時候也是買點
好 那第四個買點就是我們最近在做的
最近在做的
對 因為最近大盤急殺
沒錯 都急百點的
都急百點的
不是急百點 都2000多點
那每股都2000多點
對 台股也2000多了
1200 它一路殺 殺到現在都好
9400 其實高檔下來是真的進入到空頭了
已經進入空頭了
那空頭你要做多呢 只能槍槍反彈
對 那這個呢
就當它乖離很大的時候
你可以強反彈
乖離 小哥我覺得軍線還可以懂
出現這種乖離
乖離是什麼東西
像有這種不乖的人
我就對這種乖離
乖離我們待會會講
等一下會講
待會會講
會把我交會
對 好
那最近熱盤呢
其實你做這個的時候
那你記得一定要搭配空單避險
那你強反彈可以
因為這個美股實在太瘋了
是
那個巴爺爺說
川普太瘋了
川普說不用戴口罩對不對
這樣是麻黑
隨便啦
對 那現在連巴爺爺都說
巴爺爺說他怎麼樣
在3月初的時候說
我活到89歲啊
第一次看到龍斷
結果短短這個10天時間
他講了4次
89歲看了4次龍斷
3歲小孩說我出生3歲
我就看過3次龍斷
我出生十幾天我看了四四龍斷
八爺百伙八九歲了
好 那所以現在我們搶滿台
我們有多單嗎
對 你一定要有空單避險
好的 這是小哥的叮嚀
那空單避險這樣子
這個我們要找這些狀態的來做空
好 你說其他的5678
就是教你怎麼樣不空單的
怎麼不空單的 好
第一個 跌破下降軍線
跌破下降 意思是這個軍線
已經離開他上演
他已經彎下去了
準備往下彎
那疊破呢
那還記得我們講的扣底紙嗎
記得
這個在之前
之前出現一個高點
過了20天沒創高
月線就準備下彎了
最近很多防疫概念股長這樣
長這樣
口罩股
好可怕哦
口罩股最近長這樣
你不要以為口罩還買不到
以後會很好買哦
因為當然已經開工了
他們生產起來很恐怖的哦
好的 我好開心
防疫股這個防疫股要小心
很多股票已經在怎麼樣
已經在做頭了
在做頭了
好 那這個
第六
第一個賣點這個
第六個呢
這個捐獻往下移
然後股價稍微突破
對
這個稍微突破呢
我們現在講說叫做
棒打出頭鳥
對 只要月線往下
這個協力往下
你還敢彈到月線之上空下去
因為最近趨勢往下
你敢彈到上面的
所以剛剛有一張圖也是
它的月線趨勢往下
它站上去其實反而下去的更重
沒錯
因為快碰到月線
反而就可以空
然後這個突破更要值得空
也是一個空點
那第七個就是捐線下雨
沒辦法突破
沒辦法突破說站不回來
所以我們剛剛講
快碰到月線 你就可以賣嗎
突破了之後
踹死他
這個是我們講的空方的條件
這個第八最近有啦
中古票也有
又出現乖離兩個字了
乖離這個是在做多的時候
他有乖離太大
乖離太大這時候你可以考慮當賣方
但是過大就有點抽象
對 因為他有講到乖離
因為每個人的大認定不同
對 每個人大認定不同
要找到適合你的
適合比大小更重要
太大也不好
好
我們之前我們在講完
這個字驗證跟著
格蘭比巴大法子
其實小哥有賺到1000%
對啊 因為跌太深
跌太深我們去搶全證
你知道這個跌太深的時候
有人賣全證隨便賣
隨便賣
因為他股票被斷頭
所以全證隨便賣
有時候我們看到
哇 全站好便宜喔
去搶 你看一下貨利率
哇 1097.338
這是當天的未實現損益喔
隔天賣料是900多趴
900多趴
對 那這些
我這些對當單都還在
你看這貨利率很驚人喔
就是每天
只有一天而已
每天被你用對賬單霸凌的
就是理財單
你做的製作團隊好不好
小哥每天有秀對賬單給我們喔
神人也
好 但是這個做線骨的
其實也可以啦
他如果手腳快也是賺很大一波
對
好 所以格蘭壁真的有用喔
真的有用
好 我來考一下照
來吧
剛考完 馬上就可以考
好 各位觀眾跟著我一起看
好 找什麼
買賣點車業
好
好 來來來
我們來考這個
這個點什麼點
這個突破
這個點突破啊
這個稍微往上一點突破
他有一點乖離
對不對
還沒乖離的時候
剛突破的時候
應該要買啊
因為他出現往上了
很好 回測均線
回測均線還在往上
他應該要買
買很好
管理很大的時候
那麼多題啊
管理很大的時候幹嘛
管理很大 要空
要賣 可以獲利了解
對 很好
好 那這個
這邊開始月線有點往下囉
月線有點往下
這剛跌破往下的月線要幹嘛
再賣
再賣 對 很好
然後這裡
關於很大的時候我們要幹嘛
這邊啊 關於很大
強反彈
太好了 100分
太強了
我們公布答案
流汗了
格蘭比巴法很好用
我發現滿容易學起來的
滿容易學起來的
那今天呢
哥蘭巴爾
哥蘭膠的
強化版
就是藍B小哥爸爸
對 再搭配主力馬來操就可以
因為我們剛剛有講到
隔藍B為什麼最後抑鬱以中
是因為隔藍B是1923年出生的
那時候他少了一些工具
但是小哥現在幫你把工具補上
你會有最完整的
隔藍B小哥八大法則
對 這個就萬無一失囉
萬無一失囉
因為我們只要再多看
這個主力馬來操就可以了
好 多看主力馬來操是這樣子
這個往下的時候你到底確認說
那這個點要不要空呢
看籌碼 主力告訴你
對 狂賣了
所以台積電主力已經跑了
後面才下跌
主力走在股價的前面
因為格蘭必滴他們的國家沒有
沒有籌碼 沒有公開籌碼
台灣最幸福
第二他出生太早
當時市場沒有什麼人統計籌碼
對 沒有統計籌碼
對 然後又沒有認識小哥
對 那他也沒講到成交量
沒講到成交量 有點可惜
可惜 所以缺的就是籌碼跟成交量
這我都幫他補強了
幫他補強 好 小哥板來吧
來 小哥板
來吧 小哥板
考一下造華啦
又要考我
來 月線往上
然後呢 快要碰到一個月線啊
買
買嘛 對不對
格蘭必教我買
結果買了之後
你知道發生什麼事情嗎
不行 不行
小哥 我看到了
主意買賣籌
我有看到主意的
讓你抽看到了
在上漲的過程中 祖利在幹嘛
在賣
其實這個我們只是找空點而已
我們根本不想買
沒關係 我們不看這個
不看這個 你會想買
藍必胸買了
然後晚年就預祝了
全賠掉了
那一腳看到 哇
看到籌碼 原來祖利賣那麼兇
是
我們上面都是找賣點
對
藍必胸的賣點 OK
買點不OK
不行
就是祖利賣的時候 我們就找賣點
所以藍必胸在賣隊的時候的錢
又賠進去了
對 賠進去了
你看這個根本沒有製程
就一路往下跌
那他可能也
這個也不知道什麼時候停損
所以晚年沒錢嘛
沒錢了
沒錢心情就不大好
他有看到籌碼
哇 這個是找空點而已
好 所以小哥教我們的是
運用格蘭幣八號法則沒有錯
可請搭配就是
所謂籌碼主力買賣超
如果今天出現了
格蘭幣上的買點
可是他的主力在賣
拜託千萬不要進去喔
沒錯 好
這個是主力籌碼
那還有呢
來 再來看康友
來這邊 這個提到這邊
我們本來格蘭碧想買了
格蘭碧他出到上升趨勢線
應該要買啊 要買喔
結果隔天 一根
好重喔 跌停
再一根 又跌停
好 這時候乖離很大囉
要不要搶反彈
要
哇 它主力看起來還不錯啊
主力沒有跑嘛 對不對
那蝶破之後
這個怪力蠻大的
這個怪力很大咧
主力買這邊有小麥克
那前面是大麥啊
大麥啊
就有這邊麥 但是也過啦
對啊 主力買
結果蝶破我們要不要追呢
這個呢我們就是要看什麼
看成交量
對 剛剛講到除了主力
還要再看量
對呀 葛蘭壁沒有膠成膠量啊
就只有小哥會膠
我們有膠成膠量
是不是小哥覺得不行
對 不行不行
這種這個下跌呢
最怕一件事情
對
下跌最怕沒量
下跌最怕沒量 對
可是下跌沒量
不就是受傷的人比較少嗎
下跌沒量代表底下沒人在接
要砍沒人接 沒量
大家都躲光了
大家都躲 要砍沒人接
對 都沒人接啊
都沒人接 不行
剛剛有跌下來呢 幾根呢 14根
真的是刀子欸
真的是刀子 14根啊
哇 那個人你找到打開電視
這邊有人看這個去接的
他都是看什麼
他都沒有在看買賣舞檔的
那他看什麼
看股價 股價跌停好便宜啊
就去買
不是 那他連隔欄幣都沒看
對啊 很多人都這樣啊
就說我們不要同情了
這個不好
你一定要看到買賣舞檔的加量關係
是
你看這邊這跌下來
其實這個每天賣章的章數都很多啦
因為沒有人規定
沒有人規定碟幾根要指碟
沒有
沒有人規定
所以大家有這個心理準備
對
那後面呢
你看這邊一出量
對
就反彈
喔
所以只有這一根可以搶
可以搶
好
其他的都不能搶
都不能搶
即便主力告訴你怎麼樣
主力前面告訴你不錯
就主力出來這一根
喔
你知道主力是誰嗎
主力是誰
我不知道
這個主力
對不對
這個主力是自營商
喔
智商很可憐 因為智商在上面
人家要買他權證
他被套住了
很多權證都已經快歸零了
結果他的權證避險部位
只有在這根黑豬
他每天都要市價賣出
這天才賣出
對啊 所以我們很重要
這很淒涼
每量不要強
好 每量不要強
每量千萬不要強
或是籌碼
他主力一直在盜貨的
你都不要強 強犯他
強很危險
但是小哥老師
你要教我乖離是什麼
什麼是乖離
前陣子有部片很有名
叫做我們
與二的距離
什麼叫乖離呢
就是骨架
離均線的距離
很簡單
我們與二的距離
當然是越遠越好
我們離轉的距離
當然要越近越好
那這個到底要遠還是近
強反彈你認為
跌越深越好
還是越靠近均線越好
當然跌越深越好
對很好
跟越深彈都越高
股價離均線越遠越好
對 它公式就這樣子
好 那方間呢
小哥會幫我們算好了對不對
對 這個很簡單
例如說 舉例來說
對 月限100塊
股價90塊 是
那就離月限跌10%就到了嘛
對 關於就是負10%
就是負10% 對
好簡單喔 很簡單喔
對 那方間就建議啦
我剛講方間建議
我看了就消費 方間很多啦
小哥對方間是不友善的
雖然很多書都這樣寫
大家抄來抄去的
你去上網查一堆都這樣寫
富乖離過大
我們要買進
對啊 就疊出來吧
那富乖離什麼叫過大呢
他就寫10日均標
富7% 20日富12%
60日富7%
很棒啊 就短線均線
疊7% 長均跌到17%
真的長期疊深啊
那他就這樣寫
那這個我們就怎麼樣
這個不要看了
你學壞了
這個學到誰
我也是很公務
不要看 為什麼不對
為什麼不要看
我問你一個問題 很簡單
來
中華電信的反彈
跟國際的反彈會一樣嗎
我上當了
剛剛就講說
每個人喜歡的大小不一樣
每個人喜歡大小不一樣
對啊 中華電信的活潑度
跟國際預警光差很多啊
差多了
那我們呢 這個
這就是好不好
老實人 東方人
這是洋人嘛
對啊
那我們用統計學
統計學 統計學 統計學這樣子
我們把過往
過往這個跌到幾%會反彈
例如說中華電信過往
只要跌到1.4%
才1.4% 才1.4%
因為中華電信平常都躺在那邊
沒在跌的 沒在動的
只要他跌到1.4%
他就有95%會反彈
那我們叫做95%的地板線
那國際要跌到14%才會反彈
好活潑
預警光要跌到10%才會反彈
這是95%喔
有95%會反彈
有5%也是沒有彈的喔
6%繼續跌
所以呢我們再統計
那有沒有99%會反彈的
有 中央電信跌到2.3%會反彈
中鋼是4%會反彈
國際跌到20%會反彈
兩成才會反彈
預警光跌到19%會反彈
小哥我覺得我不用學格蘭壁啊
我就看9的9%會反彈
99%你就進去了對不對
好 你忘了我們剛剛
還有特別強調一個東西了嗎
像康有那個連續碟14
跟可以搶嗎 不行
不能搶嘛
所以我們還要再搭配什麼東西
成交量
量跟主力籌碼 對
都要看
主力籌碼 這個
通常在那時候搶的時候
通常都是搭賣的
都是搭賣的
但是我們再看量的輔助
好 量的輔助 那就很好啦
如果只要看量 我覺得
我還學得起來
好 不能只看這張表
好 那乖離率哪邊差呢
因為我自己要算 我覺得很痛苦
很痛苦啊
太好了 太好了
在那個Google info
這網站不錯啦
Google info他有這個乖離率
乖離率的合流圖
你可以看他過往呢
你說過往他跌到綠色線
就會反彈 排機電
那你可以考慮看看
或者你來看小哥的地板
天花板反轉加來監控表
好的
好 那我沒有再看這個啦
你有沒有在看這個
因為我是做我自己設計的
好
我自己設計比較好用
好 那我們先來教這個
強反彈的
對 因為這邊趙華也要說
因為趙華比較不做短
趙華喜歡長的
但是如果說
因為最近的行情
你要做長不容易
好不好 沒有這種行情
所以要學的人要記住了
小哥現在會
一步一步的教你做
但是最後會奉勸你
手腳要快一點
好 小哥 你要教到我會
好 強版台SOP
第一個 把資金分成10等分
10等分啊
可用的資金喔
那我就一分才1塊錢而已
好 第二個
當天晚上出現在地板線下的個股
好 就剛剛交的乖離率對不對
那這種地板下個股像我會過濾
對
成交量要是20均量的2倍
2倍以上
好 那這種才會出現
好 只要成交量過低的都不會出現
都不會出現
像最近國巨
我們剛剛不是說跌20%嗎
國巨跌慘了
對
他有個很大問題就是他沒有出量
哦 量沒有是這種
月均量的兩倍以上
他沒出量就跌不停
了解
所以我們這個
有人他跟我講
小哥國巨怎麼辦
我剛剛講
沒出量很危險
沒出量不曉得跌到哪裡
好 所以這個很重要囉
雖然出現了剛剛講嘛
可能99%都會反彈的
就是嗎 每量還是會跌
那第一份之間呢
在第二天殺D爆量
對 還去搶
對 那第三天開高上漲無力
你可以賣一些
你也可以爆一點 隨你
那假如第三天再殺低
對 那我第二份資金呢
我就再搶一次
再搶一次
但是這邊有講說是
第三天開高上漲無力
就先獲利了解
你可以先賣一些
這邊要先賣囉
對 賣一些
那假如第三天沒有開高啊
繼續往下殺
那我們第二份資金再搶一次
再搶一次
對 那第二份資金呢
你可以準備多一點
假如分10等分
那你第一份你用少一點
第二份再用多一點
好 六兩份這樣放下去
好 多一點
那最後一句話
強反彈就像搶銀行
搶銀行啊 對
這個搶銀行最怕怎麼樣
最怕在銀行裡面開趴
對
在銀行裡面開趴就會被抓
對 有賺要跑
沒賺還是得跑
好 小哥意思是如果搶失敗了
就停損出去了吧
對 還是要停損
因為如果這樣的話
我分10等分嘛
這樣也只有放大概3等分
對 最多也才三等分
但是如果搶到了銀行
哇 小哥其實就是
常常搶對銀行
對 一次會賺蠻多的
搶反彈去像搶銀行
我那小哥最近銀行搶很兇
而且都有搶到錢
現在他常常要用對帳單來霸凌我們
所以現在你不但要霸凌我們
你還要霸凌我們的觀眾
先教各位怎麼搶
來看2020年的1月7號
好 那這邊就選出兩黨
只有兩黨而已
當時在地板
當時有兩檔有發權證的
因為我們比較喜歡搶有發權證的
你有發權的股票至少比較好一點
也不會太小心
比較是市場上有關注的標題
不會太小心
來看喔
殺到這一根的時候出量
出量
出量隔天再殺低
我們就去搶嘛
隔天再殺低去搶
那搶完之後發生什麼事情
給各位看
發生什麼事
發生這個事情
後面整個彈上來
這彈好高耶
這個彈得太誇張了
那因為他談這麼誇張
所以我又有注意到他
對
怎麼順的 因為我去搶
結果我賣太早
到後面怎麼談那麼多
好不容易又跌下來
對
我就特別去觀察一下
順達他有直立率的行情
所以後面這一段我有賺到
後面這一段
小哥請問這樣子
我不是抱久一點比較好嗎
你叫我兩天
我兩天就完全賺不到
因為我們在一個空頭走勢
你很難想像可以談那麼高
這事後論
這私奧論哪
所以當天就是兩天
你賺到就走了
不過因為這麼強
所以我後面又特別去買
後面就有賺到最大根了
所以他歷史有時候會重演
他彈的高 跌的身上很高
歷史重演
小哥霸凌一次
霸凌一次
來看這個美麗達
特略27號的美麗達
對 2月27號地板谷也不多
那跌到這邊的時候
我們最喜歡怎麼樣
我們最喜歡看骨架跳水
骨架跳水有分兩種
一有水花 二沒水花
有亮就是有水花
有亮有水花
有水花的才漂亮
有水花你去搶比較安全
跌下來沒有亮的
就這個比較不會彈
所以這個跌下來有水花
有水花 小哥又去了
很漂亮
除了有水花以外
我們還可以看溪一點
地圖來了
另外一個籌碼面上的心腸
這叫做這個主力地圖
這是美麗打的公司
公司在這邊
公司在兩邊在元凌市
當天有兩大元凌分點大買
就是你知道
中午老闆就
差不多啊
差不多也在裡面
不錯喔
看到這個元凌人買
那就去搶
這叫做地緣性
小哥有提醒喔
台北沒有地緣性的問題
台北沒有
最討厭台北
台北也難得才有地緣性
總公司在元凌
有點眷喪大美就是很好的籌碼訊號
因為台北太多外資了 所以不好看
所以看起來有很多的利多
加持他反彈 對不對
那天在這邊
那天沙滴我去搶
結果隔天你看 哇 長了三根
開心啊 開心啊
後面又來了
這是疊更深
疊更深 然後量又更大了
這後面各位可以觀察看看
看他之後走勢怎麼樣
所以今天的網友們或觀眾們
你們有福囉
你們相信聽這半小時
其實聽了半輩子的功力
怎麼講呢
今天小哥教我們的叫做
葛蘭壁小哥八大法則
所以聽完今天的節目
如果有任何的疑問
都歡迎到我們的YouTube頻道留言給我們
因為葛蘭壁八大法則不是不好用
是要加上小哥提醒的一個叫做
成交量
一個叫做主力籌碼在哪裡
如果你學會這兩者的話
不但強反彈你會做
等正式回溫的行情
你也不會錯過囉
所以我們今天的理財大人秀
歌有求必報就到這邊了
我們下次再見啦
Bye Bye
字幕製作人Zither Harp